for money it's a welcome relief after
the extreme heat waves we've seen so far
this summer
but to some the damage left behind it
was less than ideal
madison kimbrough has been storm chasing
for us this evening
she joins us live in the southeast part
of the valley with the very latest
madison we're currently standing in a
neighborhood that saw some major damage
after today's storm you can see right
behind me the remnants
of a downed tree that's a result of the
aftermath
when lightning hits it's a very distinct
sound
and this was lightning and we heard the
crack
jack bearden speaking to us about the
intense moment on sunday afternoon when
a tree in his neighborhood cracked in
half and landed
not just on his cars but also on his
roof catching it all on video on his
ring camera
luckily his property was not damaged but
he says the weather today definitely
shook him
and the whole neighborhood up an event
like this come out
is very uh traumatic especially in the
las vegas area
i'm used to wind i'm used to rain but
during these monsoon events
totally unpredictable bearden wasn't the
only one who experienced the dramatic
weather
over at mountain's edge residents say
the rain came down hard
the lightning kind of scared me a little
bit sometimes like it got really loud
like
i saw like hail when i was going off my
window resident michael woods recalls a
time where his entire neighborhood
flooded
the water came broke through came right
across
flooded all this going all the way down
to fourth street over
this way all the way down to gomer oh
that was flooded
but ironically to this day he says he is
more of a fan of this type of weather
compared to our typical las vegas
sunshine
i love the stunning thorns when they
come love them so
i miss the best weather we've had all
year i've been waiting for this rain
been waiting
all throughout today the national
weather service in las vegas issued a
flood advisory
for several areas in clark county but
luckily right now
las vegas is clear reporting live
madison kimbrough 8 news now